my husband's best friend said i bet you
have the most number of winnie the pooh
in the world
hold my beer got to go find out and sure
enough i had the most winnie the
pooh my name is deb hoffman and i am the
guinness world record holder of the
largest winnie the pooh friends
memorabilia collection as of today at
this moment i have 20
unique items
it started kind of when i was two
my dad gave me a winnie the pooh plush
and he went everywhere with me to the
point where he was so tattered my mother
actually took a yellow fur and made made
a new one and put the fur over this
plush and so i have kind of like a poo
within a poo but i still have him and he
is in our bedroom as of today
[Music]
as a child i probably had eight winnie
the pooh stuffed animals and as any
normal child does i i grew out of
stuffed animals but i think i have a
collector jean because i've collected
things my entire life i ended up
buying a ketchup bottle telephone
somebody said well you know there's a
hamburger phone well i bought the
hamburger phone and the hot dog phone
and the pickle phone and so i started
collecting novelty telephones well as
luck would have it my first job out of
college
was across the street from a novelty
telephone store and there was a winnie
the pooh phone there and i
kind of didn't think much of it i'm like
oh that's kind of cool i liked winnie
the pooh as a kid so one day i went into
the store
and the phone was gone now i needed this
phone and so what i actually did is i um
i put ads in newspapers across the
united states and so one day i got a
phone call from somebody who had the
phone and so i think it was the hunt of
the phone
that really kind of sucked me back in
well that same year hallmark came out
with a series of six winnie the pooh
ornaments
and so here i am on the hunt again then
jc penney's had a plush uh for easter i
had to buy that plush and and before i
knew it i ended up with
a whole room of winnie the pooh items
[Music]
i've been offered 25 000 for this one i
did not pay 25 000 for this one he is
from the 1960s and he was also used at
the disney parks as well as sears and so
so that's where this one came from it
was used at a sears store and for his
age he's in immaculate condition his
body actually is
in the beginning it was about okay i
want to find this item or i want to buy
this item and now it's really turned
into the people that i meet the
experiences we have the adventures that
we go on
because of the collection
before disney owned the rights to market
winnie the pooh the rights were owned by
steven slessinger he had contracted with
a seems just named agnes brush
and so in the 40s agnes brush actually
hand made
all of these dolls each one is unique
and handmade hand-stitched winnie the
pooh went for five dollars back in 41
and that today that equivalently would
be like 97
and so uh
the value of the collection is is kind
of interesting because
many of the items i have found at a
thrift store a plush that was worth 20
in the store i pick up for 49 cents and
so if you value that plush at 20
i think we we calculated
at this moment probably over a million
dollars of value did i spend that much
oh my goodness no
[Music]
some people
don't understand collecting
they don't understand wanting to have
all this this space you know
dusting and maintaining it they they
don't understand that my generation may
be the last generation that really is
into collecting younger people aren't
interested in things they're more
interested in experiences and so you
know people who collected hummels and
precious moments i don't think their
kids
or grandkids even are interested and so
you know if you said okay well now
you're done with collecting
there'd be a void there would be a void
but at the same time
the collection is not gary in depth we
we have other interests we love to dive
we love to travel we love home
improvements and so somebody said to me
the other day well your the collection
is all-encompassing in your life
and i thought to myself it's it's not
but at the same time it does have a very
special place in our lives
[Music]
you